hey everyone this is air thread sterner
sorry end calm and in this video I'm
going to demonstrate how to walk with a
cane before a patient starts using their
cane and practicing with it you want to
make sure that they are wearing a gait
belt for safety in addition you're going
to stand on the patient's weak side in
case they lose their balance so whenever
they start using the cane they want to
make sure that they're in the proper
position the position that they want to
be in they want to make sure that they
are positioning the tip of the cane at
least four inches from the side of the
foot and they want to hold the cane on
the strong side of the body so remember
that the cane needs to be on the strong
side very important concept to remember
so how are they going to actually
ambulate with this cane well to emulate
with the cane what they're gonna do is
they're going to move the cane with the
weak side together forward so they move
the cane along with their weak side
together and then they will move the
strong side forward
thank you so much for watching and don't
forget to subscribe to our channel for
more videos